the corona virus pandemic has shut down
movie theaters across the country with
people bound to their homes they're
streaming
more than ever and some Hollywood
studios are releasing some films direct
to streaming services and digital
platforms shaking up a distribution
model that's been in place for decades
the theaters are saying you're taking
advantage of a crisis here and the
studios are saying no we're meeting
consumers where they are and a lot of
them are stuck at home this trend away
from theaters and toward digital
platforms began years ago but experts
say the pandemic could accelerate that
shift here's how this is the path a film
typically follows as its distributed in
the US the top big five studios own the
legal rights to movies they produce and
they distribute them to several
destinations say a film is made and
distributed by Sony
normally the distributing studio makes
deals with movie theaters like AMC to
organize a wide theatrical release to
over 3000 screens theaters traditionally
have exclusive rights to show the film
for 75 to 90 days a period known as the
theatrical release window after that
window ends the film usually goes to
digital platforms like Apple or Amazon
where it might be available for digital
rental or purchase later the film is
distributed again at a lower price and
may become available on DVD or blu-ray
finally the studio can sign a deal with
Netflix or another third-party streaming
service or head to cable channels like
HBO but the coronavirus crisis is
shaking up that model take trolls world
tour yeah yes Papa fur on April 10th
Universal Pictures digitally released
the film straight to platforms like
Apple TV for $19.99 for a 48 hour
digital rental bypassing the theatrical
opening
so theaters have viewed this as a
philosophical and an existential threat
for many years they want a safeguard
that exclusivity window because they
know that it is still one of the main
reasons people go to the theater right
is because they're showing movies you
cannot see anywhere else and the
experimentation over the last several
weeks with the theaters closed has
really been a source of friction between
studios and exhibitors the move was a
gamble but it paid off in just three
weeks
trolls world tour made nearly 100
million dollars in rentals the biggest
opening day and weekend for a digital
title ever NBC Universal CEO Jeff Schell
told The Wall Street Journal that the
results for trolls world tour have
exceeded our expectations and
demonstrated the viability of p VOD or
premium video on-demand theatres were
less enthusiastic whenever Universal
announced that they were going to do it
with other movies and planning then this
is key planning to release movies with
some more fluidity between theaters and
digital platforms even after theaters
reopened it really became open warfare
AMC CEO Adam Aaron sent an open letter
to Universal saying that his theater
chain the largest in the world would
refuse to show any Universal films going
forward universals decision to send
trolls world tour straight to the
digital platforms is going to be
remembered as a turning point in the
relationship between studios and
exhibitors because it's going to force
me very hard conversations when the
theaters reopened about why that might
not be a viable alternative to the
exclusive theatrical distribution model
this is all happening at a very bad time
for theaters
analysts predict there will be zero
box-office revenue in May and a 30
percent drop for domestic ticket sales
this year some are predicting that
domestic box office earnings will be
around 6.7 billion for the year down
from more than 11 billion for each of
the past five years putting 2020 on
track to become the worst year for the
film industry since 1997 a lot of
analysts expect a lot of smaller
independent theaters to really struggle
through this and potentially have to
close it remains to be seen though once
theaters reopened how many screens come
back online at the same time streaming
services are seeing a rise in viewership
in April Netflix reported fifteen point
eight million new subscribers for the
first quarter of the year more than
double their forecasts from the year
before now the big question is what is
temporary and what is permanent do
consumers say hey look why was I going
out to the movie theater at all when I
could get all this right here or will
they be so desperate to go out and get
outside of the house outside of the
living room that they returned to movie
theatres with even more vigor than
before that's a real looming question
one thing that's clear is that trolls
world tour isn't the only movie being
released straight to streaming right now
while big-budget tentpole movies like
Mulan will still have a delayed wide
theatrical release studios are releasing
more than a dozen smaller movies direct
to digital because of the pandemic in
April the Academy announced that movies
released via streaming would be eligible
for the upcoming Oscars just this year
because of coronavirus a we don't know
how comfortable people might be going
back to the theater and B we don't know
how long it might take to get them there
but the other thing that's happened is
that because so many of the big movies
the James Bond movies the Marvel movies
have been pushed to next year many
analysts are saying we might see some
cannibalization at the box office next
year two experts say that the box office
isn't likely to disappear forever
one lesson from the pandemic will be
that studios have been involved and to
experiment with these distribution
strategies more than they ever were
[Music]